yeah we went to Vegas on the tour and I
we me and God had never been so we were
like wow we want to see the casinos
because like that's that's so you do in
Vegas have a look so that was it was
crazy it was overwhelming yeah yeah it
was insane Vegas was so much fun though
it's a crazy City it's it is I mean
you've been plenty of times Joey so
you're uh yeah you're definitely buying
I I've never seen an American city that
made it so apparent that if you want to
spend money you can just like get way
better treatment yeah like we because we
were we were lining up for a cab right
um to go back to our uh hotel and as we
were lining up this line is long it's
like it's like maybe like a 20 30 minute
wait and uh this guy just shouts like if
you want a private vehicle it's fifty
dollars and I was like oh so we can just
skip the whole line if we pay 50 bucks
like yeah it's been gone like oh [ __ ] it
yeah let's do that so we just did that
we just skipped the whole line from 50
bucks it's like in my head I'm like why
would everyone here was like probably
wasting so much money on these tables
just say 50 bucks so you could skip the
line there are some people have like
lost a lot of money oh I know I know I
know any more money on taxes man yeah
I'd rather lose money on a cab ride and
tip the guy than give a casino more
money I am I am sad that me and Connor
weren't able to go to like the Caesar's
Palace buffet though that was that was a
wonderful you went to the buffet right
yeah yeah we took them
um we did my friend did this uh who
lives in Vegas is also a YouTuber
um we've got digital next uh he uh he
did this I've never seen this before or
move before but um it was a huge line of
The Season's Palace buffet right it's
like one it's in my opinion one of the
best buffets like ever okay especially
in Vegas so we were like all right we
got a lot of Staff here who've never
been to you know since the house Buffet
we got to take them to season Pals
buffet and he was like yeah the line
might be really long especially since we
haven't reserved it and we show up and
sure enough there's like you know 50 to
100 people waiting in the program it's
like a two hour wait I'm just like and
we're just standing around being like
all right [ __ ] what are we gonna do and
then my friend digital was just like all
right I I got this and he walks into the
queue and like calls over just like a
stuff and he goes yeah so uh I've got a
bunch of famous people here with me
right now
um and they really want to sit down and
they want to grab a seat where they
can't really be seen because they might
be bombarded by fans and that might be a
problem with that nobody did this and
the guy was like
all right give me a second because he
goes back and he like gets on a phone
call for like 10 minutes yeah and he
goes okay so we got a C for you right
now come on through and we just skipped
the whole [ __ ] line and went to the
biggest nicest seat in the back of the
restaurant I was like how the [ __ ] did
you do that even if I was [ __ ] like
Leonardo DiCaprio I wouldn't have the
balls today
absolute confidence in this place like
there's some famous people are just like
that's such a that's such an alpha move
that's like speech 100.
American is a different bro what does
that work I can't let that worked either
what the [ __ ] that must happen quite
often I mean this is Vegas we're talking
about right so there's probably just
[ __ ] celebrities walking around all
the time yeah I mean but it's just like
the fact that it was just like me and
like a bunch of the tour stuff we're
just standing around me like hi
and the guy looking at us like what's
the face those are the famous people
actually that's the anime man I don't
know if you know yeah I saw a uh uh claw
machine in one of the casinos really it
was like a gambling claw machine
what was in it money oh just like so you
you could bet however much you wanted to
and then it would be like hey if you've
got one of the balls you'd get this much
back uh so I tried it and I was like nah
this [ __ ] ain't gonna now this [ __ ]
ain't working this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is not
happening
at most I might get it once but because
it's like a computer that decides how
much money you get obviously the
computer will probably decide that you
get to to win when it's a very tiny
amount right so it's like it's like this
[ __ ] this is so dumb no yeah it's not
happening going on tour has made me
realize like just Conor has an unhealthy
addiction to claw machines now I don't
know if I if I see one I kind of have to
play it I kind of I don't know why it's
kind of you think I'd be sick of them
but I kind of just always want to play
them the system's going on man yeah I
know right he's it's like the jumping
effect or like all over again you've
like you've done it so much
you've tortured yourself with claw
machines so much like you've convinced
yourself that you like it yeah yeah I've
spent like God
close to 10 grand yeah I never told you
this story but like the the point I
realized that kind of oh Connor's like
actually addicted addicted was I so we
uh went to one of the uh League world's
like quarterfinals or it was like kind
of the group no it was the group stages
in New York yeah and uh we're going and
of course we're going in to watch League
that's why we're going there
um and so we go to take our seats and
there's just like one single like claw
machine in this entire building right
it's just like one thing that they've
put there and no one's like playing in
it and I just no no no [ __ ] off people
were playing no no one we were walking
in okay yeah it's free it's free to play
it was free to play and kind of just
glances that yeah and just goes oh
there's a claw machine and then I was
like yeah there's a global machine I
don't know what you can when did did you
did you know what you could win yeah so
it was like it was like a stress ball I
guess of like League things there was
like the like gragas barrel and a minion
oh yeah yeah so it was just something
for like fans and viewers to do like in
between games so we watched like the
first two games at this uh this event
that we're in
um and then Conor's like I'm gonna go to
the toilet I'm like okay sure thing I
did go to the toilet and he did go to
the toilet and so what proceeds to
happen is I
um so I so before the next game starts I
go out as well I had to go to the toilet
before the next game starts and I see
Connor on this claw machine with like
five people around him right and I just
thought I just thought oh it's uh
because actually at that League event we
got recognized so much because of course
yeah League fans and weaves we we go
hand in hand so I thought you know
Connor's just like gone is playing up
you know we had we have a few fans there
he's playing a few cool machines with
some fans go to the toilet come back
watch the match the entire match is like
I watched the entire match by myself
thinking what the [ __ ] did Connor go
where did he go he missed an entire
match of League
it was a [ __ ] game
is a group of like 30 people making a
semi-circle around Connor playing this
[ __ ] claw machine he had been playing
this claw machine for 40 minutes
and I was like God have you been here
this entire time and he's like yeah I
haven't won yet I'm not leaving until
I've won like one of these [ __ ] boys
yeah so so I went to the toilet and then
there was no line for it so and I'd seen
a line earlier so I was like oh I'll
just have a go and then I started
getting recognized a lot by people there
and so people started lining up to like
um present people were just waiting to
take photos some people just wanted to
watch me play and then some people the
people would just gather say like oh
I've heard this guy's good at this
people would just watch and so yeah like
gaunt said by the end of it I had like a
group of 30 people and it it was kind of
like but they were all interacting and
we were like everyone was like talking
[ __ ] everyone was like bantering yeah I
kind of felt like a like Spartacus with
my like audiences like are you not
entertained let's get it and I kept
getting like perfect grips perfect claws
perfect like but every single time I
nailed the grip I was there I had the
perfect Tech every single time and for
40 minutes I didn't win and then I was
asking everyone like has anybody seen
anybody win this and they were like no
no there's like three machines around
the whole venue and they're like
obviously anyone win I'm like this is
[ __ ] we should Riot we should we
should rob it we should just tip this
thing over and take its contents and so
the woman came to fill over one of the
other machines and we were like why and
then some of the guys started asking
like why can't we win this this guy's
been playing for like 50 minutes and we
can't win they're like that's easy it's
free to play a bunch of kids have won
them we're like no no one's want
anything what are you talking about the
government is lying to us begin the crew
name they literally watched me for 50
minutes nail it nail it nail it and I
didn't win a single [ __ ] time a two
dollar stress toy uh so yeah I was just
kind of sad about that and I ended up
winning no I didn't I didn't up because
eventually it was like I gotta actually
like because I'd asked uh somebody I uh
a good friend not a good friend I know
somebody I knew hey can I have tickets
please because the tickets were all sold
out so I was like I should go and watch
the game so after after 40 minutes like
that's enough that's enough Jesus I like
how you was a free claw machine I was
like and you were like I want a refund
give me a refund
of my time that was [ __ ] up League of
Legends uh if you ever watch this clip
please consider sending me a free uh
stress toy uh because I needed it
afterwards that was unfair
I bought so many white claws at that
venue and they were they were like 15
White claws oh my God I needed to get
through that claw man I was like I was
so sad